any parallels between then and now in
terms of any type of the shift I think
that you're always finding groups of
committed ambitious young artists and
films a collaborative medium so you're
always finding people who are exciting
each other igniting each other
stimulating each other and collaborating
together that is the nature of film
nobody does this on their own nobody
does this alone and so I see now
students coming out of NYU forming
collectives now the Internet is a
content creation machine so there's all
kinds of opportunities for students who
are coming out of NYU where they've made
films together in class and now they
form production companies and they do
branded content that's essentially short
films that are showing their craft and
exercising their skills while they're
making that film that's going to be the
Sundance winner it's a really exciting
moment what are one of the number one
maybe fears or sort of doubts in the
minds of a lot of the students that
you're talking to today well I think
that what everybody's concerned about is
that there's this tsunami wave of
content there's an overabundance of
content and how do you emerge
I mean after you've been making your
YouTube videos what's next now back in
the 90s there was it was a lot harder
there were fewer opportunities there was
much less access films were shot on
celluloid there were a handful of
distributors only one or two festivals
that was interested in indie films so it
kind of winnowed out a lot but it also
meant that if you did something of
quality there was a clear route and
people would see you whereas today would
they find you it's the same question
people ask if the Beatles you know put
their music up on Pandora or whatever
would anybody notice them and that's a
real concern how do people emerge and I
have any answer I mean I think it's
about this generation is gonna have to
figure it out that's what I say to my
students it's on you now you know we got
either this point you're gonna have to
form your own future and they will they
will sure
you